so there were a bunch of questions about
you guys kind of like pre YC and I think
maybe the easiest way to do this is like
flow through from there so like before
you guys were in YC and then fellowship
and then Corps and then now so going all
the way back Phil Thomas asked what did
you learn from the fellowship and that
you applied during the main YC core
program yeah I think so we did the
fellowship in winter of 2016
huh when Kevin Hale was running it and
so I think for us YC fellowship was all
about like figuring out product market
fit and like figuring out what we were
because we didn't know when we got in we
were basically the concept was this like
cooler curated Etsy so everything was
online we would find these cool emerging
brands sell their product online and
like have like a Content element to it
and so it wasn't really working we had
like some brands selling with us but
there was like clear problems and so I
feel like fellowship for us was about
like acknowledging this wasn't worry day
yeah and like really an actually heaven
like be really good for that
yeah it really is yeah so acknowledging
that wasn't working and then it's almost
kind of gave us permission to just
totally tear that down and try a million
other things I think before we kind of
got into YC it just got into that whole
mentality we were like this is our
company and this is what we're doing and
we're gonna just keep doing this and
until it works and I feel like Kevin and
like the program in general basically
allowed us to be like okay this isn't
working let's try it like literally 15
other concepts and see and get something
with some momentum and go with that and
so I feel like we basically used it I
think was two months that program and we
were just ran like experiments every
week so we're like okay what if we and
that's most of them were ridiculous what
was the worst one okay the worst one was
so we were selling all of this abuse
where and like don't and man emerging
brands on our site and Kevin was like
why don't you go to restaurant
and see if they need help designing
their stores and like if they need like
a programmatic like interior design
solution or like a way to replenish like
forks and knives and stuff so we spent
the entire day the two of us like
bopping around to different Brooklyn
restaurants and being like how do you
like find your notice and this is like a
business where they like like razor thin
margins really what do you think about
like if everything was handmade and like
way more expensive and like probably
brakes were like no we would never use
this yeah and we also knew nothing about
the restaurant industry and like there
are programs that they they're some guy
pulled out his phone and was like here's
an app where I can order like 800 limes
on demand do I need it like this has
been figured out already and we're like
so that was definitely the worst the
worst one and the funniest funny and
then like so by the time you started
working on your product as it is now
that was before YC core right that's
what you applied with well there was a
whole like chunk of time after YC
fellowship where we had realized that
this editorial magazine model wasn't
working we in the spirit of YC asked our
users so we asked all of the brands that
sold on our platform what they wanted
and it turned out that they actually
needed more help selling offline than
they did selling online so they weren't
really looking for another like
multi-vendor online marketplace or
another Etsy or anything of that nature
a lot of them made boatloads of money
doing like craft fairs and selling in
retail environments or doing pop-ups or
markets and so what we did was we
listened to that and we said okay what
if we basically just started doing this
as many times as we can as frequently as
we can as inexpensively as we can just
to see if there's there there so I'll
let alone take over how we found our
18,000 square foot parking lot basically
we're an outdoor
oops pitch tents in rain or shine in
this almost 20,000 square foot parking
lot in Williamsburg for six consecutive
months the worst we we Bo the idea was
that we wanted to test this concept
without spending a lot of money and like
that's kind of what we did from the
beginning and so we were just looking
for the cheapest possible space to run
these things and it works the same way
it works now like the brands that pay a
weekend fee they come up they they come
up in person and sell their product and
so we looked everywhere in the first
place we ran it was at a bar there was
like a bar with like a big courtyard and
so these brands we had like 40 brands a
weekend on a good weekend and they'd pay
like about $300 a weekend and that would
give them a table and a chair that we
provided it would basically come and
like set up their product like a little
booth and we were just like run a market
for Saturday and Sunday
so our weekends and are a lot like it
was this is all we would do and so we
did it at this courtyard and then we
wanted a bigger space so I found this
like massive burger oh it looks like
like a toxic wasteland good I like it
was totally overgrown it's it's like
this asphalt parking lot sitting on top
of a swamp
so it's like primo obviously you cannot
develop on this property yeah God it was
a very good location it was like in
Williamsburg in Brooklyn right on the
subway stop and so we just called like
the phone number on the parking lot like
yeah I mean I deal with them I got it
for super cheap where we could use that
every weekend and yeah we ran it from
like April of 2016 till the end of
October yeah that year and it was a
total nightmare because we were outdoors
it was like green or would be like the
middle of July in New York City and like
really Browns would just like text us
and be like it's a hundred dollars we're
not coming
really yeah cuz okay because it would be
so hot it would be like to gently like
yeah like it was crazy we're a few
weekends that were inhuman yeah but the
good thing was that we were like
starting to actually make money and the
brands were making money and we were
like starting to prove out the model and
we can see like okay we now know like
we've proven that like brands want to
sell in person and they'll pay to sell
in person there's definitely this like a
lack of you know easy to access physical
space and yeah I feel like we were able
to like prove that that's summer okay
and then so at what point did you decide
like all right let's do I see so at the
at the end of October we were like this
is crazy like we can't do these markets
anymore and so we started we were like
what would be like a more long-term
solution and so we started looking at
actual physical retail spaces like just
a normal with inside and so we found a
store which we still have now it's like
a great store in Williamsburg and we
basically moved to the same model this
like like membership-based model to the
store and so the brands would pay this
monthly fee they'd get access to space
but the store was totally run by us so
they didn't have to show up and it
allowed us to like work with larger
brands and so we we really felt like
that model was working even better like
we were onto something bigger or like
this isn't just gonna be like another
early we booked it out and less than two
it was crazy
yeah like we had I want to say like 35
brands paying the membership fee within
12 days of announcing that the store was
going to open Wow and so these are all
people that were doing the parking lot
version some of them were and then some
of them were a lot of the parking lot
people were like Pete
see you know some of them were from the
party yeah yeah they're a lot it
honestly I do want to call it there are
a lot of friends that have stuck with us
like from the very but mostly it was new
mostly it was kind of opened the door to
like other types of like slightly larger
brands that like maybe wouldn't sell on
a parking lot all weekend but like who
they're not carried and Sephora all over
the world yet okay so like to put a
finer point on that Brian Chappell asked
how did you actually find your first
customers like so you feel that quickly
but how did they even find out about you
so to answer that I'd say we when we
launched the digital like shoppable
magazine version of bulletin we would
just reach out to brands that we loved
be like can we do a profile on you and a
long interview and original photography
and make this beautiful page for you and
they'd be like yes so we would do that
they would see zero sales on our website
but it's so pretty it was really like no
one had anything to lose in this
situation and so through just
maintaining those relationships and then
eventually moving into the market model
we reached out to those brands that had
been on the editorial site they you know
said oh I know these two girls that I
worked with on this previous iteration
of a company would recommend other
brands to do the parking lot and it was
honest so we always had a great referral
okay and I think that that was how and I
think with opening the store it was
basically tapping the network of brands
that had been doing the pop-up and then
you know creating a nice little email
and sending that to brands on other
ecommerce sites that we thought might
want to sell in person we obviously
looked at New York now renegade other
sites that did this like IRL sales thing
that we were trying and just always had
very I would say like very successful
outreach with potential customers and we
still I think we still do yeah and what
was your um what was your strategy
around pricing how did you figure that
out once you open the story as far as
the membership yeah and everything yeah
I think we had an idea of what brands
were willing to pay from the markets
like we could look at an existing market
and see like okay this one is a massive
one and they were torching $1,000 a
weekend and so we started very low um
and yeah I think we had an idea of what
they would pay from that and then move
that over to the store but like even now
we keep that number like very accessible
for brands like we like the idea of you
know brands that are merging to be able
to partake in this and you get like a
very wide er range of brands that that
would sell in the space just kind of
cool okay because yeah I mean like what
kind of scale are we talking about like
what are do you even know the annual
revenue numbers of a lot of these brands
yeah I was saying on the smaller and you
have brands that have literally just
started like they maybe sell their
products on Instagram and like they
probably don't even tell you what the
number is revenue wise which i think is
kind of cool to have like a certain
percentage of the products in this store
yeah be like this very homespun vibe but
there's I mean we have brands that sell
on Sephora we have brands that are like
big brands that are doing I wouldn't say
big brands but maybe they're doing like
10 million a year in revenue oh okay um
so they're still you know out there
building their brand but like they have
manufacturing figured out and
distribution and yeah just like a much
more established brand okay got you so
adora had a question for you about store
expand yeah partners yeah well ship and
been there from the from the beginning
oh gee she asked you about a couple
things but one of which was store
expansion so for you guys like how do
you think about opening up new spaces
how do you find them do you think it
will work in every city what are your
thoughts yeah for us um so we have
started in New York City obviously we
have new stores here will be doing one
more store in about a month so we'll
have three stores for 2017 and yeah I
think we it's tempting to want to just
do this very quickly we have so much
demand from these brands that want to
get into spaces it is expensive to open
a store like there's like real costs
behind all of this obviously so
definitely trying to be careful there
but I think now that we have
of these two successful stores well you
know have the third opening soon it gets
easier for us to like look at the data
to understand like what's performing
what products are performing what
neighborhoods work best for us and I
feel like even now like we have such a
good idea of like what a successful
store looks like like as far as square
footage as far as far as location and
the types of neighborhoods so we're
getting smarter about it and I think as
the company grows it's easier for us to
actually look at things like customer
data to understand like what the next
city is so like we have our online
business still like understanding where
those customers are from helps us decide
like okay maybe la is the next place
that we're going and dat just be smarter
about it and not go crazy yeah I will
say when it comes to how we pick actual
stores and the availability of stores
real estate is in crisis right now in
particular retail real estate and I mean
you can speak more to it but we don't
really have a dearth of real estate
people like reaching out to us to have
us help them make their spaces
successful yeah which is really exciting
that you know both ends of the
marketplace when it comes to having a
wait list in Williamsburg and Nolita
for our two stores and then also having
this like pool of you know real estate
folks that want us to open bulletin
spaces for them and with them it's it's
really exciting okay so can you
contextualise that a little bit for
people because I don't think it's
totally obvious like even in I'm trying
to think like maybe it was in Carroll
Gardens where there's just like strips
aren't like on main drags of like stores
just vacant how did that happen and like
how are you guys making money off of
that opportunity I mean it's good for
our business but I think yeah I think
everything started to change a little
bit as like people's shopping behavior
has changed I think like Amazon
definitely plays a role in it I don't
think it's you know the entire reason
that everything has changed so much I
think people have less of a reason to go
the store for like their normal like
just utility kind of purchase and so I
think those traditional retail stores do
like get hit because of that and then
for us it does turn into an opportunity
because I think all of these property
owners are brokers like they'll cut
deals with us that we would have never
gotten nine months ago like if you want
to do you know a short-term license
agreement and test out a location and do
it at a discount with like the option to
renew like there's just so much that we
can do now because of what's happening
what's happening meaning like a single
store is just way too expensive
yeah there's basically a mismatch
between the cost of real estate and like
how much it traditionally costs a brand
to take on a lease also restrictions
around how long that least should be you
know brokers and property owners want
five to ten-year leases they want
long-term leases but for brands you can
see by all of the like hundreds and
hundreds of brick and mortars mm of
brick-and-mortar stores belonging to big
brands that have closed this year alone
that they're not like the store is not
their profit center anymore and so it
just it it surely does not make sense to
like throw tens and tens and thousands
of dollars behind a lease every month
and you know do build out and staff and
maintain it when there's you know who's
to say that that will actually yield
crazy revenue for right I think it's a
it's not obvious if you live in a big
city you're like what are you talking
about I was reached like all these
stores are opening up everywhere and in
reality most of them aren't even making
money they just look cool to be in Soho
well there has been a crazy spike this
year I just read a report in how many
stores are opening like there are a lot
of brick-and-mortar stores opening but I
think that's only possible because real
estate like players are realizing that
the terms that they've set for their
inventory to date is just not gonna fly
anymore
I feel like it a lot of it comes down to
like what the what brands are using the
stores for now yeah I think is like what
has really changed so rather than it
being like you know kind of an
old-school retail brand sign
a 10-year lease and being like we want
our customers to come here like buy
product I think you see a lot of these
like newer players and director consumer
startups that are using it as more of a
marketing channel or as a way to
interact in person with this like
massive digital audience that they've
grown and so in those scenarios like it
doesn't make sense for them to sign a
10-year lease like that's doesn't like
if you are comparing it to like a
Facebook ad or like some other kind of
marketing you wouldn't buy like a 10
year Facebook ad or something like you
would it makes more sense for it to be
targeted and short-term and something
that is experiential and more on the
marketing side then like yeah like your
major profit but real estate like hasn't
caught up to that yeah yeah yeah so you
got weird time are they are they
catching up to you like are you guys
this like arbitrage right now until the
market changes or is this always going
to be an opportunity I think that you'll
see a lot of these directory consumer
startups especially the ones that have
been around longer and you already see
people like were we doing this where
they have like more traditional longer
term leases and and I think that totally
makes sense for them but I think you'll
see a mix of both I think like it's nice
for the customer to have this kind of
influx of rotating stores and
experiences but I think for I think for
like the smart direct-to-consumer
startups that like nail the experience
and nail like the purpose of their store
it like you can kind of move into a
long-term lease and that's actually like
what we're starting to do that with our
business like we started off with these
six-month license agreements where we
would test out a space and in our
Williamsburg store and our Nolita store
it like it works well for us we've kind
of nailed the experience and so now
we've moved to long-term leases there
okay and so like we have like much more
reliable supply or we can put out brands
like months in advance and not be kind
of like
[Applause]
yeah too bad yeah do you guys have did
you have to get fancy with your
fundraising cuz this is kind of
non-traditional right like having all
these leases and stuff is it different
than a normal startup raising money I
think for this stage it didn't seem to
be too different I think we definitely
you know ran into a lot of questions
about like who's like a physical like
thing and a real estate thing and like
there's a lot of questions obviously but
I think we had enough traction and data
to show that like okay the unit
economics of this like shared retail
space works
and that it is very scalable because of
the membership model but yeah I think
anytime you're dealing with real estate
or anything I think we work definitely
paved the way yeah I feel like okay we
work with their co-working model granted
you know they're light years ahead of
where we are it will take some time to
get there but I think that you know
given how well they're doing and their
valuation and just how like prolific
they are and how many spaces they open
up it's like oh okay physical space
isn't necessarily like the scary devil
like end-all of it's not gonna kill us
so yeah luckily we had them as as a
roadmap so speaking of killing a door
ajar asked why did old department stores
like just die off like what so many
reasons I think it's a few different
things than Ilana kind of touched on
this the way that the internet has just
changed how we shop the internet will
win at a series of things that stores
will always fail like with the internet
you can get anything you need
immediately there's a wide selection you
can toggle for a specific price in a
specific location a certain delivery
date I think with department stores like
that's what they still do is like when
you walk into a department store it's
just like a massive empty space with a
ton of different product categories it's
not tailored to a specific customer
there's no like experiential or
discovery element and it all just seems
kind of odd
there's like kitchenware with like
maternity clothes with baby clothes with
like fancy handbags just like this a
never-ending yeah and it's and it's like
if I wanted to explore product like that
like if that's where my head's at I'm
just gonna go on Amazon or I'll go on
the Internet or I'll go on
Bloomingdale's com I'm not gonna like
physically show up so I think department
stores have failed because the things
that they're good at are the things that
the internet is good at and the internet
will just always win because it's right
at your fingertips
I think the other thing that department
stores aren't good at is just product
selection and you know replenishing the
store with fresh new product they can't
be super reactive oftentimes they're
buying a ton of product up front they're
doing like crazy flash sales to offload
products that they can make way for a
new product but that just seems to
cheapen the entire department store
experience so I feel like they're just
kind of stuck in this weird middle
ground where the things that they're
doing to try to improve or actually
hurting them in a lot of instances I
don't know if you'd add anything to that
I think in a lot of cases too they have
these massive footprints and these
stores have been around for like a long
time so it's there's it's no easy task
to be like oh that's just renovate you
know hundreds of stores around the
country that are massive like they're in
a very difficult position we're yet
innovating it's not easy yeah for them
and we're obviously at an advantage of
very new having like two small stores
but I think for us like we're able to
see like okay we know that like we can
compete with Amazon and like the
internet right with experience and with
these stores that are experience driven
and that are like you know built around
a certain community and so like being
able to start from that point and build
from there it makes it a lot easier for
us to do that yeah obviously there's the
one it's heavily curated right like
you're definitely picking people picking
vendors rather so how are you deciding
like what goes in a store so Mike mal
cow I mispronounced everyone's name and
they say it on everybody
it's okay how do you know what users
want at these stores it's honestly it's
a ton of data feeding into our selection
process so we look at Instagram we look
at the posts that are performing well
not only on our Instagram but like what
is going on in the zeitgeist of
Instagram right now like what is our
customer looking at what is she like in
what is she engaging with even just
their you so you've segmented two female
buyers I just asked for both of our okay
stores we obviously look at sales like
we this this like successful store
didn't crop out of nowhere like as we've
told you we had markets that sold
product we had this initial version of
the store before we turned it into this
editorial theme that sold product like
we have three years of data around
things that have definitely not
performed well and then the things that
have I've done pretty well so that
information has been really helpful and
then Maggie who I mentioned earlier
basically goes through all that data and
looks at the brands that are applying to
sell with us and she says okay this
brand is great but like these are the
five products that will perform best or
like we're really low on this product
category I think it should be this
aesthetic over this one because last
month like this crafty look like didn't
do well across five different product
categories so it's very there is like a
lot of data being fed into the decisions
but we always have like our own human
touch on what we think we in ways we are
our customer so it's like we're not like
what do we like but we intervene it's a
little bit of our taste throne was there
something that you both loved and didn't
do well at all a product yeah I'm sure
oh yes I can think of something so I was
in LA for a period of time in 2015
during our editorial version and there's
this amazing amazing designer his name
is Andrew Hahn first name Andrew spelled
normal Hans felt Haan okay he does these
insane
beautiful like hand-drawn geometric
prints on graph paper and I did this
whole photo shoot with him this long
interview he's like the kindest most
lovely unbelievable man in the universe
and we put his stuff his his work in our
Williamsburg store and I think he's so
and granted they're they're expensive
they take a lot of time um they're
around like to it up like a hundred
twenty-five to $250 depending on the
print and he sold to and like that was
that and that was just kind of us like
loving him and loving knowing how much
labor went into these prints and like
how detailed they were and we thought
they were absolutely stunning and they
just didn't perform but has art
performed well in the past
prints do yes I think what we've learned
with both of the stores and just in
general is like the lower pricepoint
products work for us and so we've kind
of made the entire vibe of the store
this very like accessible yeah point
like less than 100 bucks type stuff even
and then like I like our average order
value right now I was like 40 bucks and
so I think it's it adds to the
experience of it we're like anyone that
walks in can buy something it's not this
like exclusive and accessible place we
were just looking around being like cool
I literally can't hear and so yeah I
think everyone it kind of like puts a
smile in everyone's face
yeah and knowing who our customer is and
what her disposable income looks like
based on our information it's like you
know I don't think there's a world in
which at this point we'd ever create a
store like that because that's just not
chic she can't shop should we do that
that's funny okay so going back to
applying for YC both of you are
non-technical is that accurate okay what
is your advice so Deepak asked what's
your advice for non-technical founders
applying to YC I would say I mean for us
that we applied three times so we
applied for fellowship we applied a
middle time where we didn't get eggs we
had just pivoted to the market thing and
then we applied the third time and
finally got in but um I think to be able
to like one be persistent and keep
applying but I think for us we were able
to show a
lot of traction every like six months
when we were playing mmm like even when
we started like Ali and I were still
working at our old job but like we had
built all this stuff and built this
whole like editorial site the second
time we applied like we had this whole
new model and we had like revenue and it
was like it was yes we had just pivoted
but we had done a lot in a short period
of time and then I think the third time
the big difference was we had a ton of
traction we've been working on it for
over a year and I think we were finally
able to make the argument that like this
is very scalable and then for the
non-technical side to be able to like
really explain and like explain
confidently that we didn't actually need
that at this stage of the business so I
think obviously like you know most YC
companies like have a technical
co-founder and that's like a massive
part of their business I think for us at
that stage like we were really able to
explain why we like weren't really at
the stage just yet where we needed it
and I think we were approaching the
stage where we were going to need it and
now we have a bunch of remote developers
that are holding everything for us but
yeah I think we were just able to really
show that like for this stage of the
business like we're okay without a
technical co-founder so same advice for
you Ellie yeah I would say the same
thing I think definitely speaking
confidently to why you don't need that
person I mean I think something that we
always really emphasized was like we
were cobbling together like pre-existing
platforms that did what we needed at the
time yeah so for us it's like we're
focused on building a profitable
business and why should we spend time
building a technology when we don't even
know what it needs to look like yet we
clearly from telling you our story we
had no idea what we were building didn't
build anything because it would have
taken a ton of time and a ton of money
and Alana and I both from the get-go
we're like we want to create something
that from day one someone is handing us
money to give to them like we want to
create a service we want to create a
product that we know people need from
the start and then refine the service
and the product around that customer
so now we're building this platform
after learning for the past two years
like what tech do we need to do like
retail as a service in this way like how
will our customers work with us like
more easily and more efficiently through
this technology like what do the
elements actually have to be right I
guess the the advice I'd give would be I
mean if you're building eight if you're
building like a very - if you're
building software like get a technical
co-founder like you know it's it's
really important to have someone by your
side to go through the ups and downs and
if the product is gonna be tech from the
start like I don't really know why you
would outsource that yeah
but otherwise if you're doing something
unconventional like us we were doing
like a retail real estate business you
know just really go in there ready to
explain why it's you know the tech isn't
necessarily first and foremost right now
and I think we like by showing
everything that we had cobbled together
was kind of impressive on its own like
well we have Squarespace doing this and
we have Shopify doing this and like
there was like six different existing
platforms that were really doing the job
and I think our biggest bottleneck was
like figuring out all of these things
about the business and about the next
space and real estate like it had
nothing to like technology wasn't
holding us back in any way so I think
proving that helped I think that's a
really great piece of advice like
something that people even on the
technical side should consider because
so often they're like well should this
be in Ruby or Python and like how much
machine learning do I need before I
apply to IC and for the most part no one
is using their product like get it out
there and like see if how people would
use and yeah if we had spent a ton of
money building some like beautiful
editorial platform and we would be like
out of business on the way to front this
is the easiest way to find silverware
that's so good do you uh do you remember
what the actual numbers are this is such
a common question I figured I'd ask like
what did your growth look like before oh
I see when you applied successfully um
when we before we applied like the zero
no yeah so this would have been like
October of last year
we our growth numbers were great then
because that's when we started to do the
markets every single weekend and then we
had just launched the store so that
summer our numbers our revenue is like
doubling every month because we were
like had more and more markets coming up
and all those were fully booked out and
then we had just launched the store so
we had like six months of space to
booked out for that and all of that's
prepaid so like our numbers looked
really good because of that okay and
it's just kind of tangentially but you
guys have counterintuitive opinions
about retail that you like you think the
markets changing in a way that most
people don't I rely I have like
everything swings like a pendulum so I
don't know I I think about the store
that we're opening for holiday for
example and the entire like ethos of the
store is like bringing back the
nostalgia of like going with your
girlfriends or your family to the mall
and like like getting these malls yeah
like getting you know walking out with
like a ton of piling it into the trunk
and I feel like with so many things
going on right now with like the state
of our country and how the internet and
like all of this attention being on the
internet and all this time spent being
on the Internet has just like kind of
reached a tipping point where I feel
like people are looking and being like
like I don't know if I want to be like
staring at my computer all day or like
staring at my phone all day or like in
this Internet world 24/7 I feel like
there is gonna be a pendulum shift away
from this and toward like interaction
and being in person and connecting
face-to-face and so I don't know when
that's going to happen obviously these
things happen in like decade-long chunks
but I hope it comes soon and I think
that that definitely informs how we
approach
retail and how we approach building our
stores like in our holiday store there's
going to be like a lounge area and
activation area where people can like
explicitly do events and do workshops
and do things where there's like
community building and actual human
interaction so I don't know if that's
necessarily counterintuitive but I feel
like a lot of people are figuring out
trying to figure out like how do we make
Instagram more shoppable or like how do
we make our newsletters more shoppable
or like how do we do this and it's like
my greatest joy in life is walking by
our Nolita store on like an odd hour on
like Tuesday at like 3 p.m. maybe and
seeing that it's packed and just feeling
like wow they're like I'm we're not
wrong and there are women not like
actually want to physically show up in a
store and they the customers communicate
with each other and they all I always
get DMS on the bulletin Instagram about
how much they love our retail staff and
it's like it warms my heart and it just
makes me confident that like this could
be the direction retail is going in and
if so we're on the cusp of it yeah I
totally agree with that I think you also
see a lot of a lot of trends in like
in-store retail design right now where
people are getting like magic mirrors
I'm like these crazy screens in the
store and like you can connect your
online account and like just all this
technology in this chat you're online
but I think that's something that we
have really shied away from I think that
like we really like the store to feel
like this you know in-person experience
and it's not about like kind of going
back to the internet or like somehow
having a screen in your face again and
so I don't necessarily know that be
counterintuitive but I think for us yeah
to approach the store design in this
like new way where it is about the
community in the store and about the
experience in the store and not about
like another was their future is there a
future of your store without any
employees I don't think so I think
that's for us it's such a big part of
the experience I think there's some
technology that we are thinking about
that will like ease the checkout process
or like the point of the employee being
there isn't to ring them up which is
what they part of what they do now so
I'd like to free them up even more where
they can just spend
interacting with the customer but yeah I
think like the in-store team is such a
huge part of the experience and like
makes that probably like 50 percent of
the like positive feedback we got so
yeah we still need humans I'm sorry if
you weren't working on bulletins right
now what would you work on work on it
together we will we would we have like
gone through bulletin or would it just
be like bulletin ever happened
oh all right alternate reality uh no so
today
okay literally - that [ __ ] goes crazy
somehow in it well it's still going on
say like you can't restart it you have
to do something else okay I definitely I
think I mean I don't wanna speak for you
I feel like we're both at a place where
I don't see us ever going back to like a
normal yeah job or like working for
someone else again I don't know what I
would do though like I feel like this is
just I think I would love to do I mean
for me like the most fun part about what
we do is like the store design and like
bringing like life to these kind of
weird old New York stories as weird as
that sounds and so I think something
with that I could like I can be happy
doing okay maybe yeah just designing
others so basically bulleted I don't
know I would definitely be writing I
write a lot for bulletin across like our
email and our social and like the
editorial site that we once had
it's deaf it's like it comes very
naturally to me and it's one of those
feelings I know like coders get this way
when they code it like makes me high and
when I'm writing something so I don't
know maybe I'd write a book or become
like a tech journalist or I don't know
work for a good cause I can on profit of
some kind and handle their
communications I think that would be
really fun what was the most meaningful
thing you learned out in YC
I would say I would say working when so
Michael Seibel was our group partner and
I just feel like he was always so good
about getting us to focus on like the
one yeah thing that we should be
focusing on and so part of that was just
like him being brilliant and like
picking the thing we should be working
on but I think getting into that mindset
of like really really identifying like
what your actual one issue is and not
were like I don't know I think like YC
is it's a crazy busy time and there's so
many things to be worrying about like as
it always says when you're running a
company and I think just always going
back to that and being like okay like
what is the one thing that you need to
be working on in solving and like the
thing that can actually affect your
business and not getting bogged down
with like the millions of other things
you could possibly be doing and he's so
good about justice on yeah that one
issue I think something that we learned
in both YC fellowship NYC core in both
instances we were working in isolation I
mean during YC fellowship we didn't have
a team and then during YC core our team
was mostly based here and we would go
back and forth but work together in San
Francisco I think I definitely learned
especially since it was such a pivotal
time for us and we were growing and
figuring out like what the one thing was
like the ability to to listen I think in
group office hours just the way that
that structured where you literally go
around the room and listen to every
single founder talk about the problems
that they're facing you know you give
suggestions if you have any like stake
and what they're doing or if you have
any expertise of like ways that you can
help and I think just listening to each
other like when you're together all the
time in that very like pressure cooker
environment you have to make very quick
decisions you know you have demo day
coming up like what are you gonna
present what business are you building
like what is going to be the thing that
helps investors understand it like this
is the future and I think they really
shouldn't be missing out on this
opportunity
and I think just yeah I think it was one
of the best times of us like bouncing
ideas off of each other and just amongst
a group of really intelligent people
that were doing such different things so
yeah I think it made me a much stronger
listener overall yeah I mean it's such
an interesting experience thinking back
were you I don't know it's like the one
time where everything else in your life
really stopped completely you did yeah
it's so crazy and I mean I guess it
always feels that way in a sense when
you're running a company but I think
this was like the one time where we had
you know moved out of New York like
moved out of our apartments and
everything and yeah it's just such an
interesting kind of experiment to move
through working what happens when I
literally don't do anything else and
when I'm living in like a studio like a
500 square foot studio with my
co-founder eating every meal together
and it's just all you do and all you
think about and so yeah I think like
that level of intensity is just it was
really cool to do that and I think
coming back here and kind of like
returning to normal life like that
obviously stuck with us but I don't know
it's just like a cool thing to go
through also pick a good co-founder yeah
because if you end up doing YC and even
if not like your stuff it seems like
things are going okay yeah no I feel I
think I don't know I feel very lucky all
right thanks guys thank you
you